割れちゃう、お前なんだよみたいな
あんまり
そう、だからかもしれない
だから単純にもう、楽しいとこ切り口に
中には、なんかこういう人、毛がこんだけしたんだぜみたいな
無憂伝じゃないか、語りたい人いると思う
一回聞いてみていい?
今どういうケースかっていうのが
お名前を教えてください
あ、そっから?
そんな、超恥ずかしいんだけどね
お名前を教えてください
かんのいとです
かんのさん
答えられる範囲で、職業、年齢、出身地?
もう、それちょっと事務局通していただいたかないと思う
職業は?
あ、年齢不詳
年齢不詳
職業規定?
ネイトです
出身地は、高尾だよ
あ、超、超そこわあほい
さっき聞いたからね
そうですね、まあエンジニアですね
あ、エンジニア
車会社のエンジニアです
あ、クライミング歴は、どれくらいですか?
くらいならもう、大学年齢から13年ね?
13年確かに、13年ね
ホームジムは?
今は三鷹ジム
三鷹ジム
3年齢は、9、奥義版
カンパチにあった時
ソフォスタートですね
新鷹、新鷹ではない
関係カードは、何枚持ってますか?
売りのほうまいね
カンパチにあった時
10は?
10くらい
10くらい?
うん
海外が多い
あ、え?
そうなんだ
うん
そう、増えちゃうんですかね
そうそう、増える
今は週にどれくらい?
週に
うん、近日に
他にやっていたスポーツや習い事は?
めっちゃいっぱいある、スポーツは
あ、そうなんだ
うん
水泳やつ
そうだね
まあ、水泳から始まって
サッカー
フェニス
えっと、スケボーとかロールでスノード
いい?
とか、ボルフ
うん
そのあとは野球以外はほとんどやっていないな
そうなんだ
うん
そんなやったの?
やったか?
そう
サッカーも僕やってたけど、初めてに
うん
だけど、どうしてもやっぱ
サッカーとかフェニックって相手が必要だから
はいはいはい
それで、何かもっと一人気楽にやりたいなってなって
その時、たまたまやったらクライミングで
そこからハマった感じ
あ、なるほど
うーん
初めてクライミングに触れたのは
でもそれこそ
何きっかけ?
あれだ、大学の時に
マコトくん
マコトと
マコトもう一人いた
あのー
伊藤ってやつが
いて、そいつらは
なんかね、登山じゃないけどやってて
で、そう、クライミング
最近行ってんだけど、あいつもどうよって言われて
行ったのが最初に
おえー
ジムなの?
あ、それがあのー、木を置いた
あ、なるほどね
うん
こっか、その後僕誘ってもらった
あ、そうっすね、そうっすね、たくさんの後買った
初めてクライミングで感じたこと?
初めて?
いや、純粋に面白いなと思ったっすね
うん
なんでかっていうと、自分は筋トレが好きだったから
はいはいはい
なんか、よくあるやりだけれども
力さえあればできそうじゃんって思ったのがきっかけで
うん
実際やってみると、全然歯が立たない
最初5球、4球
初日5球、4球がもう一杯一杯で
いや、でも4球触ってるのすごいね
うん
だけどなんか、それがある意味面白かったなっていうところかな
はい
できるだろうみたいな
そうそうそうそう
確かに
あ、そこからもっと変わってくれば
うんうん
より面白さもっと変わってくんだけど
じゃあ、今もう続けてる理由
一番の理由
一番の理由だと思う
健康っすね
健康以上
うん
あのー
あのー、クライミングってその当時よく言われてたのが
なんと、クライマーやってるから痩せるよねって言われるんだけど
実は痩せないってことで
あー
すごく酸素運動だし
なので、クライミングでよく登れるために痩せる
食生活とか
体維持するっていうのが必要で
ちゃんとしたレベルのものを登るっていう
自然的にクライミングやるために体管理をしっかりする
っていうことはもう日常的にクライミングファーストで置けば
体が健康な状態を維持できるよね
そこがまず一番
あー、モチベーションになる
まじそこ
クライミングやめてた時期は?
コロナ
どれくらいの期間?
1ヶ月くらいかな
ほんとそれくらいしかありがけたことないかも
それだけ?
すご
そうなん
1ヶ月くらい
ない
じゃあ、生活の中で
クライミングの優先順位はどれくらい?
クライミングで大切なもの
大切じゃないものをそれぞれあげるとしたら
これいいんだその
まあ、仕事
まず一番仕事
仕事が上
で、次クライミング
次クライミング
うん、もう次クライミング
そうそうそう
次に僕が好きなワインがあって
で、料理があって
で、次睡眠みたいな
他の趣味とか
そう
ワインが好きやね
今日もワインの?
そう
今日は多分、ビール、ワイン、日本酒
全部
そう、強いの?
え?
強い
そこそこ
弱くない
ワイン?
生活維持しつつ
あのー、なんだろう
好きなワインとか料理は
飲んで食べたいから
クライミングでしっかり移動する
おおー
え?
ワイン?
でもクライミングが一番強めな
趣味の中で
そうね
うーん
ワインを先にしちゃうと
どうしても
体の健康維持ができない
だから
クライミングが一番で多く
確かに
とはいえ
仕事がちゃんとできてなければ
登ってる
なんでも登ってるんだってなるから
まず仕事がしっかりする
はい
で、次にクライミングで
ただと思って
楽しいワインとか料理を
充実させたい
結構
うーん
ちゃんと
考えてますね
ちゃんと考えて
優先順位
実は
始める前と比べて変わったと思うことは
えー
クライミングで
そう
クライミング始めたら
大学の
うん
始める前
あーなんか
そうね
自分の
体
なんだろ
ある課題があって
自分だけが
どう登れるか
を
よく